let's go to our next caller from the
8:03 area code 8:03 tell us tell us who
you are and you can go right into your
question hi my name is joshua jenkins
I'm here in Katy South Carolina
Joshua before we go any further we're
not on speakerphone are we no I'm
hearing we have my headphones oh okay
all right sounds like a head like a
speaker but we'll deal with it go ahead
here's three things one I think the
Republicans are trying to cover up their
corruption by saying that some of the
content in video games and singing video
games help learn from another news
outlet about the use of modern music and
there's a Stargate hurting the video
gaming on one's called gangster rap
mainly do it by Ice Cube and I think the
Republicans are trying to find an excuse
to cover up their corruption for the
parkland shielding okay I don't know
what you're talking about Joshua I'm
doing the bet I don't know I have no
idea what you're talking about
sorry it's just a lot of Republicans
have came out and blamed some video game
content about parkland shielding okay
yeah blaming violins and video games for
real-world violence yeah all right
I think Joshua has hung up oh no he just
has absolutely yeah I don't understand
the question and we can barely hear you
so I'm gonna have to move on but listen
we've talked about violence in media and
the connection to real-world violence
before so definitely check out check out
some of the work we've done on that